Hollywood was once very nice to Sasha
Baron Cohen the British comedian who
broke through in the u.s. of 2006 is
Borat cultural learnings of America so
make benefit glorious nation of
Kazakhstan welcome to our country okay
my name of auda okay okay good good you
set up that's fine sense it around and
often crude sexist and racist ie
reporter from Kazakhstan
the comedy opened up opportunities for
Cohen to star in a wide range of big
movies like Talladega Nights The
Dictator Alice Through the Looking Glass
Leigh mr. Rob and more but despite that
string of roles Baron Cohen hasn't
popped up on the big screen quite as
often as he once did and here are a few
reasons why family man unlike many of
his peers Baron Cohen doesn't turn out
multiple movies per year and that's by
design Sasha and his wife actress Isla
Fisher have three young children and
they both want to be active present
parents co-owners committed some only
making a movie every couple of years
while Fisher plans to only take
supporting roles until their kids are
fully grown while these Hollywood
parents love to act it sounds like
they're putting family first at least
for a little while real world reputation
even if Baron Cohen wanted to keep
making reality blowing movies like Boris
he doesn't think he could a victim of
his own success he fears he's become too
recognizable to pull off a movie like
for a tour Bruno again on top of that
there's also the matter of the inherent
danger in making these kind of movies as
Baron Cohen's films have definitely
landed him in hot water in the past and
the idea of the movie was actually to
end it with inciting a riot in Arkansas
while me and my co-star made out on
stage he was lucky to get out of that
one in harm's but even a minor non
deadly stunt from Sasha can end up being
very stressful when Baron Cohen made a
surprise appearance as a DJ at the 2016
Academy Awards people were genuinely
shocked because the show producers had
specifically told him not to do it this
caused some stress for his wife who had
to be complicit in the prank and even
smuggled the Ali G costume into the
awards ceremony under her dress he then
had to help her husband get into
character backstage and Ally to the
producers who were trying to figure out
what he was up to so it's really
stressed I think honey honey
going to work and then I had to go out
finally and I said you know something's
wrong with his stomach
Fisher did what any reasonable person
would do after faking out 20 million
people on live TV she hit the bar the
brothers Grimsby Baron Cohen's last big
movie was 2016 so brothers Grimsby like
some of Baron Cohen's previous films the
mismatched spy comedy made headlines not
for its creativity but more for its
shockingly crude moments the movie was
wildly unsuccessful both commercially
and critically as it really seems like
almost no one was connected with this
flick it was one of Baron Cohen's few
leading roles in a movie in which he
didn't play a character interacting with
real-life people and audiences just
weren't that into it
one-hit wonder between 2000 and 2004
Sacha Baron Cohen created three main
characters for his comedy series - Ali G
show Ali G Boris and Bruno and by 2009
he had brought all of them for the big
screen while Ali G in the house wasn't
released theatrically in the u.s. 2006
as Borat was a massive hit bringing in
128 million dollars and earning Baron
Cohen and his collaborators an Oscar
nomination for screenwriting this is
black
uh not in 2009 Baron Cohen brought his
third and final character Bruno to movie
audiences but he was unable to recapture
the magic of Boris Bruno a mockumentary
about an openly gay fashion obsessed
Austrian weirdo is seriously
underperformed bringing in less than
half of what Borat did and in doubtedly
slowing down Baron Cohen's rise to fame
breakthrough dramatic role in 2010 it
was announced that Baron Cohen was
considering starring a singer Freddie
Mercury to whom he certainly bears a
resemblance in a biopic about the late
Queen frontman Baron Cohen was actively
involved in trying to get the movie off
the ground even consulting major
directors like David Fincher and Tom
Hooper but in 2013 he decided to pull
out of the project and the film still
hasn't been made the actor claims he
left the project because the surviving
members of Queen wanted the movie to be
a relatively tame biopic about the
entire band on the other hand Baron
Cohen wanted it to be purely a Freddie
Mercury movie showcasing the later
Oxbow's wildlife Queen guitarist Brian
May offered a different
in on the issue suggesting that
baron-cohen would have to be a
distraction as he doubted that the
larger-than-life actor could actually
disappear into the role and do it
justice what's next well we likely
haven't heard the last of Sacha Baron
Cohen and it wouldn't be surprising if
he's working on another big character
right now from what we do know Cohen has
two main projects in the works for the
last few years the first at a timely bit
of satire called greed in which he plays
a money-mad financial loss skirting
billionaire the other is a big-budget
film adaptation of Mandrake the Magician
in which he'll star is a total character
a heroic master of illusion seems like a
good fit thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]